(Thunder)
(Lightning)
Vera Farmiga:
Five Days At Memorial is a show
about doctors and nurses
Vera Farmiga:
in a hospital during Hurricane
Katrina.
Vera Farmiga:
Who find themselves abandoned,
overwhelmed, and forced to make
Vera Farmiga:
life and death choices under
extreme duress.
We have this intense medical
ethics drama
Carlton Cuse:
taking place during this huge
natural disaster,
Carlton Cuse:
and we wanted to be sure
we told both of those stories equally well.
When we first started, we did
rain outside the hospital.
Marcus Rait:
And so we have very large hoses
that come from a distribution tank in the parking lot.
Marcus Rait:
And two "ten" power fans and two
"twenty" horsepower fans.
Marcus Rait:
We put smoke behind the fans to
create that kind of haze of catastrophe.
♪♪
And you could hear howling out
there, the wind machines.
Julie Ann Emery:
It sounded really eerie.
It's pretty loud, yeah.
♪♪
Marcus Rait:
It looks fantastic on the
inside.
The walkway was one of these
incredible scenes.
Marcus Rait:
The glass walkway gimbals, so it
creaks and shakes and glass breaks.
It’s not done in post, it’s
actually very little left to the
imagination.
Vera Farmiga:
There's some genuine fear,
-(Laughs)
in those scenes.
♪♪
David Antonkiuk:
Action!
We have a massive outdoor pool.
This tank holds approximately
four million liters of water,
John Macgillivray:
and we've used a food
preservative and dyes to tint the water.
Layton Morrison:
We’re gonna have police boats,
fan boats ,
we’ll have people walking in the
water up to their chests.
This is insane.
It's gonna be a real experience
in a 4-4 1/2 foot pool.
Layton Morrison:
Also we have a basement set.
It's water coming!
We had holding tanks on the
exterior of the building.
Layton Morrison:
And we drop twelve-hundred
gallons of water on them in five seconds.
Adepero Oduye:
You just have to say wow.
I feel like I am there,
Adepero Oduye:
at Memorial during Hurricane
Katrina.
This is the most dedicated and
invested crew I have ever worked
with.
I've never felt so supported by
a group.
♪♪